[Aplausos]
hace cinco décadas la humanidad puso a
un hombre en la luna y ahora nos
enfrentamos a un reto todavía más
ambicioso
estamos preparando marte para nuestra
llegada
y todo esto es porque detrás hay la
inversión de miles de millones de
dólares y muchos esfuerzos de muchos
científicos y visionarios y también hay
algunas cosas tan insólitas como los
humedales
la nasa que está llevando a cabo
investigaciones en el parque nacional de
yellowstone en los géiseres para
identificar cómo es la vida o como
podría ser la vida en marte
y esto es posible gracias a que estos
humedales termales se han preservado
cuando yo estudiaba en la universidad
mis compañeros tenían muchas dudas
acerca de qué especialidad iban a elegir
porque había muchísimas opciones y yo no
tuve dudas no voy a dedicar a los
humedales esos grandes olvidados
o puede que os parezca un poco rara o
puede que esto nos interese pero bueno
también me parecía que me fascinaban los
misterios que tenían los humedales me
parecía que formaban parte de mi cultura
y también que había mucho
desconocimiento sobre estos ecosistemas
entonces pues
estas pues puede que esto nos interese
como os decía antes porque realmente las
preguntas importantes de los humedales
son te gustaría convertir una paella al
lado de la mujer a una paella
espectacular o te gusta el risotto o la
pizza o qué me decís de estar en una
playa de miami junto a los everglades o
que me decís del agua fresca y pura que
tomamos cuando tenemos sed pues bueno
todo esto no sería posible sin los
humedales
los humedales son unos grandes
supermercados de alimentos
y especialmente de arroz la mitad de la
población del mundo en oriente sobre
todo se alimenta de este cereal y son
grandes amortiguadores o parachoques de
fenómenos extremos de la naturaleza
por otra parte los humedales son grandes
almacenes de agua dulce y además ayudan
a recargar los acuíferos subterráneos la
mitad de la población europea depende
para el suministro de agua potable de
los acuíferos subterráneos
bueno estos son los beneficios visibles
que tienen los humedales pero también
tienen otros que son más invisibles y
ahí radica en parte el problema
por ejemplo los humedales son limpian y
depuran las aguas dulces actúan como
tienen como unos filtros como unos
grandes filtros a manera de un gran
acuario donde se auto depura en todas
las aguas
por eso son conocidos como los riñones
del planeta
además secuestran el carbono atmosférico
más del 30% del carbón atmosférico está
inmovilizado en las turberas del planeta
y esto es más de lo que hacen los
bosques tropicales
y además son grandes reservorios
biológicos y genéticos el 40% de las
especies de fauna del planeta viven o se
reproducen en los humedales
pues bien podríamos preguntarnos todos
los gobiernos del mundo estarán muy
interesados en conservar en proteger los
humedales porque son fantásticos y nos
dan muchos beneficios pues bueno nada
más lejos de esta idea
los humedales han sido ecosistemas que
han estado perseguidos han estado
destruidos han estado degradados
solo en el siglo 20 del siglo pasado más
de la mitad de la superficie de
humedales del planeta desapareció fue
destruida
nos preguntamos bueno
qué pasa con esto qué pasa con esto por
qué está pasando esto pues bien la
respuesta es que no nos interesan no nos
importan es decir a mí me importa su
conservación y puede que a ti y a ti y a
vosotros os importe pero a nosotros como
sociedad los humedales no nos importan
y quien tiene la culpa de esto es que no
nos importe bueno pues la culpa la tiene
el oso panda
el oso panda o bien digamos que el hecho
es que en los humedales no hay osos
pandas no hay koalas y no hay otros
animales que sean peluditos achuchable y
que generen nuestra empatía y que nos
animen a
a quererlos no
el general está resulta difícil generar
este tipo de relaciones emocionales y
personales con algunos ecosistemas y en
particular pues con este que estamos
tratando que son los humedales porque la
fauna que hay en los humedales son
reptiles peces insectos
y nadie quiere escuchar a un cocodrilo y
tampoco a este
entonces
nuestra inteligencia ha evolucionado lo
suficiente para comprender temas
complejos pero nuestras emociones no son
muy primitivas este problema no es
exclusivo de los humedales le pasa a
muchos otros ambientes han sido hay
muchos otros ambientes que han sido
objeto de prejuicios por parte de la
sociedad
y
y han sido perseguidos por y han sido
porque eran insalubres porque eran
improductivos y han sido objeto de
desaparición
está esta situación nos preguntamos qué
podemos hacer nosotros para que no
ocurra esto cuál sería la solución a
esto pues bueno la solución es la
divulgación científica
y porque la divulgación científica nos
ayuda en resolver estos problemas bueno
porque nos ayuda a tener otra percepción
del mundo de las cosas nos ayuda a
romper prejuicios el conocimiento
científico no se acerca a conocer a que
lo invisible sea visible y que lo
visible sea apreciado
lo que no se conoce no se aprecia y lo
que no se aprecia ni se conserva ni se
protege y por tanto
y la comunidad científica tenemos que
dar divulgar cada vez más y mejor y
focalizar y orientar esta divulgación
sobre las cosas importantes y no sobre
lo aparentemente hermoso por otra parte
la sociedad tenemos que tener la
responsabilidad de no dejarnos llevar
por lo que es fácil cómodo o hermoso
sino que nos tenemos que involucrar en
cosas que realmente sean relevantes para
nuestra vida y para el planeta
a diario vemos que se protegen o se
conservan espacios que no le importan a
nadie o le importan a muy pocos
pero yo tengo la esperanza de que esto
va a cambiar y porque va a cambiar
pues va a cambiar porque creo que la
divulgación científica
va más allá de la mera curiosidad
personal
genera una opinión cualificada y una
opinión cualificada empodera la sociedad
y una sociedad y este empoderamiento
hace que la sociedad que se genere o se
desarrolle la dimensión social de la de
la conservación y la protección y una
sociedad que se preocupa y que quiere
que se proteja se protejan
los espacios naturales y los espacios
culturales es más garantista es más
garantista que la opinión de unos
cuantos científicos
además
nadie a los científicos nos quitará
nunca la ilusión de divulgar la ciencia
porque divulgar es compartir y compartir
nos hace mejores personas y mejores
investigadores
en fin yo no sé si en algún momento
viviremos en otros planetas
pero de momento debemos asegurarnos que
aún podemos vivir en este y para eso
hemos de darnos cuenta de que la
naturaleza sus recursos sus especies son
todas importantes y que es
independientemente de lo hermoso de lo
atractivo o de los conocidos que sean
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]